hamid's caught up with Palestinian
prisoners who faced abuse while
incarcerated and sent this report from
the occupied West
Bank he might be home but still acts as
if Behind Bars pacing up and down his
hands in front as if handcuffed his head
filled with unanswered
questions I feel I am still in prison I
am psychologically tired and in pain my
body is numb non-stop headaches I feel
electricity down my spine I can't get
out of bed because of the pain they used
to hit me all over the body Basel was
15y old when he was first arrested
sentenced to 2 and a half years on
charges including resisting police but
as a teenager he often rebelled against
prison rules it led to several jail time
extensions totaling 11 years behind bars
seven in solitary confinement the last
18 months with no visits or outdoor
time the impact is so deep basil was
scared to be released begging to be
returned to his cell that's him frail
long beard and disheveled hair and a lot
of pent up
anger I'm his mother but he didn't want
to come to me he didn't recognize us on
the way home he attacked us hit us got
out the car and ran away he was annoyed
with me even though I'm the only one who
saw him in jail it deeply affected me
not able to deal with a return to
normality Bassel needed urgent treatment
this is the hospital where Bassel was
admitted 4 days after his release it's
the only Psychiatric Hospital in the
occupied West Bank and we're here to
speak to his doctor to understand the
longlasting impact of solitary
confinement and
detention doctors say Bassel displays
the symptoms of deep
trauma we think this behavior stems from
what he lived through any physical
contact was aggressive there was torture
humiliation degrading treatment so this
kind of prisoner feels that any human
touch is a negative
gesture ABD fat do has spent two
sentences in prison one as a child and
later a 12-year one for participating in
the first
in until today and it's been seven years
now my phone has been on silent I like
the quiet I prefer to listen than talk I
don't like public places too much any
noises around me disturb me I don't show
it but I feel different inside 10 weeks
later Bassel is still
confused addressing me as his doctor
Lost in Time still not acknowledging his
parents I respect the family of Abu Adam
I am an orphan when I was born four
months ago these people looked after me
they fed me and took care of me to tell
me to call them mom and dad but it's not
possible since I'm an orphan right where
that must hurt parents who had been
waiting for over a decade to hug their
son but still denied that moment this is
one story unique but at the same time
not uncommon the dark reality of living
under military occupation that is only
getting more Brutal by the day
abdulhamid Al jazer in the occupied West
Bank